then I had to go to freaking McDonald's
I don't even remember what'd you have I
don't even remember then you remember I
remember and you don't want to tell me I
didn't I don't even remember I know that
you know remember no this is a grinding
gross it's fine I didn't have anything I
won't be I won't tell me and then we'll
tell everyone why no
it was just it was gross what did you
eat chicken nuggets or a chicken
sandwich I had this chicken sandwich was
disgusting so Ben doesn't eat out he
tries Ben tries not to eat non-kosher
meat I struggle everyone knows but
sometimes you come to tell me no you're
too judgmental I would have understood
late night long day McDonald's who
understands better than me no but and I
didn't even want it like I'm here eating
and I'm looking on the menu there's no
mcplant which by the way make plants
might as well well be make Cancers and
like honestly yeah I don't subscribe to
it I agree they also don't have filet of
fishes which by the way that can't be
sustainable fishing I don't think that
God wanted me to eat this unsustainably
caught fillet of fish 100 he'd rather
the chicken